yo yo what's up man it's your boy sean
fontino man aka franklin from grand
theft auto 5 man i'm checking out these
clips man and we're going narrow right
there and have fun man with game spot
man come on y'all let's go let's get
ready that
you said a man is stuck in a tree
and he needs my help
part of you would rather leave him here
because he's a bit of a
doing your
a real dog a cool dog chop was a the
first chop was a mean dog officially
lost my mom
his parachute failed to open
and now you kind of wish he'd missed a
but tree is a human construct and you
are not hard wired to think that way
i can't believe i'm getting smart talk
about [ __ ]
hey hey the crazy part of the body is
shooting that um
we were really using a real labrador man
it was a real dog you know and uh and
the dog was actually real cool man and
it was a dude standing right here
and he was the trainer so you know i i
say what i say and then you gotta wait
in the guy go he do something in the dog
then i'll run my lines again and then
look at the dude in here do something in
the dog a bark again so i mean it was a
cool scene but you know when you're
doing motion caption
you don't see it like this so i didn't
understand what it was but then after i
saw it in the game man it was it was
hilarious you know what i'm saying so
well the company's part it didn't come
natural it would just happen to be funny
and then um
i didn't know a lot of things i was
doing was funny because i'm not that
much of a funny guy on camera i probably
am more in person
but when i was doing the lines and i was
after it was over and everybody was
laughing the director and everybody and
i thought they were laughing at me but
they were laughing
you know the comical you know script of
it and stuff so that was cool you know
what i'm saying so i started saying damn
i am kind of funny you know
can help come up in your crib man [ __ ]
you i see you at work
because i'm beautiful maybe you got rid
of that old yee ass haircut you got you
get some onion oh better yet maybe
tanisha call your dog did she ever stop
with that brain surgeon the lawyer she
went
what yeah that's historical man that's
viral virus you know um with that scene
man that was just we freestyle pretty
much
you know
it was it was written different a little
bit but
uh of course dylan was slink crazy ass
you know he's always going to
take us in if we if we all trying to go
left he's going to take you right so you
have to be ready for his you know what
i'm saying so
like i say all the time man i i i don't
think this would have been as good if it
was if if i wasn't doing the
the scenes with sling you know it could
have been another actor but i don't
think they would have made it authentic
as
as he did you know i i actually thought
we were doing too much because
when we were shooting again and when we
were shooting this
i kind of like start thinking man maybe
we saying just hood you know what i'm
saying so i was kind of like
i was kind of actually telling him to
not do it i was like calm down man and
he said okay he was like yeah you right
man let's let's switch up and let's kind
of stay to the script a little bit
but
after we just after they say and action
it's like we just couldn't help it but
to fall back into who we were who we are
as you know black men and stuff that
grew up in the hood so and i guess that
that brought a lot of you know realness
to it you know i'm saying because we
just me and him we just did things
naturally
but the things i had to do with um like
trevor and michael um
it was pretty much i had to like get
into a performance you know i mean i had
to like
try to perform with them because they
were two great actors so i had to try to
pick up my acting skills which i had
zero at the time you know
it went crazy you know and i woke up one
day and
my instagram was just moving i said what
the hell going on i just looked up and
the followers were moving and all these
people just in my dm bugging me sending
me a whole bunch of roads from
everywhere i was like what the hell is
this darth vader um mickey mouse minnie
mouse goofy and uh
after
a week or so of it
man man slink just like hey man we need
to shoot this man we need to go out and
reenact this man and it came out good
man you know we we reenacted it and we i
went and bought the clothes the exact
clothes franklin had on and he put on
the same stuff frank lamar had on it
we thought we did a good job and that
went viral what
we are women we are free we're bringing
into the thank you our team we are women
you are pain we are women
we are women we have no doubt we are
women we are free
thank you
no really
oh so what it's just me getting hurt is
that funny no man
you i'm gonna put you in the ground you
laugh at me again
calm down like like remember i was just
telling you like i was saying that i
couldn't be myself and i couldn't fire
back off as being tough
that's a prime example right there
that's the king of the example what i'm
talking about because when we shot this
scene
and he fell over the gate and i was
laughing and he came up and he started
saying what he's saying and he was like
i put you in the right i fired back off
at him one sec like you ain't gonna put
me
i'll kill you first and they were like
cut
you know the director was like no solo
you have to let him be the more
aggressive dude you know i'm saying
so
this is like the prime stuff of you
seeing me
happen to just
okay man okay i thought it was funny at
first
my bad homie you know i had to like
reshoot the scene and play the uh
the punk in my words but really the the
smarter dude to try to make everything
smooth you know i didn't know that i was
the
the smooth guy to
to clean things up and make it okay but
look how about this man
calm down
it was funny at first man i made a
mistake
unfortunately man you failed
it it was real awkward to be honest with
you um it was a
i think that was a take number
50 something because
i just thought for about 20 takes i just
couldn't get over that i had to let this
dude talk all this in my face it was
hard dealing with it because steven is
so good that it was unbelievable and i
used to get
caught up into what he was doing
and i would snap back and then i
i have to reel myself back in and get
back into understanding that we're
acting
because you know i mean i mean i'm from
a neighborhood just like this man and
ain't no white man to come in there and
act like that with another bus hell nah
he'd be dead
fast i was trying to still figure out
where
did i fit in any of this like what's
going on
what is happening why
you know i'm used to san andreas the cj
just being the man and all that type so
i was he started sitting down explaining
to me that
trust me man
franklin is
is this is going to be based around him
everything is going to just just go with
the flow you're going to love it at the
end of the day you're going to
understand it when it's all over with me
i started learning after that after he
really broke it down to me about my my
you know where franklin was going
through this video game
after that right there i started
understanding that okay it makes sense
let me let me chill out let me stop
trying to trying to want to be hard you
know what i'm saying
so
i mean it worked out you know
look at the contract i'm the
man in there
[Music]
yeah when i got the uh when i got the
call
to say hey um we're bringing you back
it was like
it was perfect timing to be honest
because
i wasn't on the fence of getting into
this business of doing this and when
they called
it was exciting to be honest man i was
like
but i thought they were bringing
you know us back you know
the crew back but when they was like no
it's just you
and i was like damn for real they were
like yeah you gotta you you gotta come
to new york we're gonna send you some
script we're gonna get you in contact
with the travel person and all this i
was like
you know i just started saying my
prayers i was just like thank you god
you know what i'm saying i was just so
thankful you know after eight years you
know almost nine years i'm i'm back
and then when i got
there
and started reading the scripts that
they were sending me and i was like wait
a minute this is a different franklin
and i was like how is he gonna look what
is he gonna do because you know eight
years down the line my voice changed i'm
getting over you know what i'm saying so
i was like how's this gonna work out can
i find to be franklin again after all
this time and yeah it was it was easier
than i thought the only hard part was
the director coming to me and saying
cut cut
you're a boss now
you you you you don't have to act like
the the guy you know that has to be hold
on hold on no you are a boss this is
your building this is your desk this
fancy this this he was just breaking it
down to me and i was like oh yeah
you're the boss
man you you gotta you gotta remember
just getting a phone call saying these
are the people you shouldn't work with
everybody is iconic you know what i mean
um dre is a
iconic producer um writer
um music person rapper you know what i'm
saying dj pooh is a legend in the in the
music business the movie business from
la you know he co-wrote the movie friday
he produced his own movies he his his
music his production is tied to
everybody in the rap game he's done
beats for everybody you name them you
did it ice cube snoop dogg llc you just
name it he's an icon jimmy alvin come on
man you know
what can you not say about this guy you
know what i mean so
they were finna come into my world and i
was trying to be the boss i was going to
be the mogul i don't care how big dre
was how big jimmy was how big dj pooh is
and these are people that's hey man i
look up to i idol
but y'all finished stepping into my
world man you finished stepping the
grand theft auto motion caption
franklin world i'll run it but y'all
don't you know what i mean you need mama
help so
um
i was looking forward to that i was
really looking forward to being
the go-to guy
it woke me back up as a uh i mean the
fans already love me that's real fans
that grant their follow you know but
this just put me back in the line like
it woke me back up it brought me as
my government name sean fontino back to
life you know because it brought
franklin back so
now let's start all over again when i go
places you know people recognize me they
see me
you know they acknowledge my work
um
they asked me all the questions you know
i'm saying and i try to answer them to
the best i could you know
and um
it's it's like reliving
2013 you know late 2013 like november
october november december all over again
top top man to be honest with you
when they brought the dog on the plate
shop he brought a real rottweiler home
and he was
he was a mean
man he means
he was like man watch out get this
man so
um
they end up bringing another dog on to
work with to work for us to work with as
chopped and it was a lot it was a lot
better it was a lot cooler you know what
i'm saying but then they
i don't know if i can say this they they
end up bringing a a big ass fake dog
right
he's like
get up in the top and he just grab the
motion caption suit on this fake dog and
throw his ass in the van
[Laughter]
so uh
i mean working working with the
imaginary shop it was good man you know
so that means that i
you know we were acting pretty good to
be acting you know with a [ __ ] dog
man come on yeah
[Music]
so i mean i didn't understand that i
didn't know that was going to be the
ending you know i'm saying i didn't know
what that was about
but um uh picking a b or c
i mean of course everybody that played
the game um you you you probably wanted
to pick them all so you can see which
one how the endings would be
the the the crazy part to me is when i
found out that
i wouldn't
d
for a b or c you feel me so
it was like i was like damn
i i am franklin is more
a little more important than i thought
it was there because you you can't pick
a
you know c is not franklin b is not
killing franklin and a is not killing
franklin so
of course i'll try them all cuz i
recorded them all so i wanted to see
what it looked like with the performance
but
me overall picking what up if it was me
to have to pick something after playing
the game and knowing these dudes
yeah i would definitely pick c you know
what i mean because then my boys man we
went a whole lot together in this game
and
you know of course you know michael he
he looked out for me you know like his
like his his own kid or his his little
brother or his little home to be honest
i thought that you know i was only going
to be around for
a half a year six months eight months
you know what i'm saying but
because i thought the you know the life
expectancy of a gang member in real life
you know what i'm saying they don't it
don't go real long but then i got to
think you know it's a video game but
then
after working on it for a year and a
half going on the two years i was like
damn
i'm
still here
you know what i'm saying like
like i'm still working
to the very last day i'm like
okay
okay i'm feeling something now you know
um you know i didn't know what to expect
but
it turned out better than uh then i
it turned out way better than what i
thought was gonna turn out i could add
things onto my
my my bucket list like man damn i went
viral you know um i'm part of a
of
one of the biggest things in
entertainment you know my name my
likeness my my charisma who i am is tied
to something gta 5
one of the biggest
things in entertainment man that's not
too many people can say that you know i
mean coming from where i come from so i
know i'm truly blessed you know i can't
thank god enough man you know i just i'm
so thankful that i was picked to be in
this opportunity so you know i always i
always say and i believe in man you know
what's for you is going to be for you
you know what i'm saying if it's written
for you
you just got to see it and recognize it
and grasp it and take it and run with it
because you know a lot of us we get
these opportunities and we overlook them
you know what i mean
because i was trying to overlook this
man i didn't even want to come to this i
didn't even want to come read for grand
theft auto man when they first said it
back in 2010
11
i didn't want to have no parts of it man
i was
i would have lived in my life and i was
telling dj poo when he called me to come
hey man you should come read for this
video game i like now i don't want to
read no video again even like bro i'm
telling you so i just started thinking
about my cousin which which his name um
play he plays cj
you know san andreas his name is melee
he plays cj so i just start thinking
well let me just go
at least do the video games so i could
tell him that's how i started so i could
say yeah i got i got one two dog
i didn't know it was gta 5 like they
said they told me it was a game called
paradise bro so i was just going along
to get along but
i can um
i say this all the time man grand theft
auto has immortalized sean fontino
my name will live on
much way past me you feel what i'm
saying when when i'm old and gone and
going into the afterlife or wherever we
go um
people still be talking about
franklin grant their father and then
that's tied to me so
i did a good job i had myself on the
back
yo man i had a good time man thanks for
watching man i enjoyed this with y'all
look follow me on instagram solo118
or you can follow me on twitter at sean
solo fontino
on
tick-tock at sean solo fontino facebook
sean solo fontino and also go to
sologamechanger.com
order the book order the audiobook order
the graphic novel the digital book is
everywhere it's that apple books borings
and nobles amazon it's all over the
place right now and we're doing good and
you can order some of this merchandise
you can get this you can get the hat you
can get everything off of that website
sologamechanger.com
see y'all